hey everyone it's Mikael BOS and welcome
to the orderflows market analysis for
Monday July 24th 2017 it's kind of a
quiet day in uh equities not much
movement and even bonds was were pretty
quiet so uh let's just jump into it
before I get started brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation of buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures training containes substantial
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment rate
risk capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results now the tools I use in this
presentation are the order flows Trader
and the Delta
scalper okay so first I'll talk about
the e- minis this is the 10 range chart
and just to give you an idea how quiet
the day was you know coming in at uh you
know 4 in the morning we had a a low of
uh 63 and 3/4 a high of 70 and a half so
about a what is that 7even point range
more or less and okay I mean that's fine
you wait to see what's going to happen
when the day opens we make a new low at
5: in the morning and then we start to
Rally got Delta scalper giv a nice uh
Buy Signal here goes up in the next bar
gets within two ticks of the high and
then just you know goes pair shaped on
you and we just go sideways over the
next few bars we come down test the low
we don't make a new low trade down to 63
and a half now there's a couple things
on this
low one you got a nice strong positive
Delta 4,000 that's uh you know that's
that's bullish for it and second time
you hit this low first time you hit it
you got 265 second time you got less
volume 118 which is also a nice little
bullish sign it's telling me there was
less interest in selling into this low
trying to break out and Delta scalper
kicks off gives a nice buy right on this
low here this and so again we make
another rally up from the uh 66 area
back all the way up to the highs so
again you know there's not much um meat
you know in these moves today because we
have such a limited range but you know
we you know the tools that I use like
the Delta scalper are giving you you
know some some opportunity some chance
to get something you know this first one
honestly it's it did just you know there
was just nothing more to this move and
came around on you and you know just one
pair shaped but then the second move
right off the low is tell when you you
know there's a shift you got buying
coming back in
and you know this is tells you how slow
the day was this is this bar finished at
1040 and you get up here this is the
cash close uh just very very slow grind
so you know maybe it could have got
something out of this move here you
could have got you know two or three
points out of there but it's just
nothing going on so there there's not
much uh opportunity but you you're
getting the signals right and you know
even though it's a slow grind they are
going in the right direction okay next
uh I'll talk about crude oil here so
this is uh September crude this eight
range chart and around 3: in the morning
just you know 3:10 you make a new low
here you have a bullish ratio you don't
have a Divergence got small Delta though
minus 22 and you have this green arrow
here which is generated by my software
just telling you you know that there's
some potential trap Traders down here
then the next bar very strong positive
Delta Delta scalper even kicks in and
you know we make a move up from this uh
55 area 40 5 55 um you know a nice move
up all the way up to you know the 7580
area um we do come
off come back down to the the 50s for
rallying um making new highs now at this
High we got a couple things we've got a
ratio and a
Divergence this is the ratio this is
Divergence so you got the negative Delta
and then in the next bar you know you
got a bearish ratio telling you that
there's some stopping volume there next
bar you've got the Delta scalper kicking
off Delta really picks up here it goes -
7 - 65 -600 so you know there's a lot of
selling coming in right on this high and
what happens Market sells off it then
just goes sideways before you get
another wave of selling coming in here
minus 300 on the Delta here Delta
scalper even gives you another sell
signal and you know we come off over the
next two bars before turning around at
508 and start
rallying into new highs you know we're
coming up breaking out to these new
highs got a lot of buying and balances
not stacked they're sort of spread out
but you know that's still um still
carries some importance going back into
this High here you got the Delta scalper
given another buy and you rally up about
uh 10 or 15 cents to a new
high and then you hit this swing low
here at uh 806 right after it you got
Delta scaler giving you another buy and
you know again you go up from the uh 15
area up to new Highs at 38 go sideways a
bit you know make a new high here at
this High you have a Divergence no ratio
though and that was about it for the day
in the uh in the crude oil okay so uh
you know really quick I'll talk about
the Delta scalper a bit you I've been
getting a lot of questions about the
Delta scalper recently so you know one
of the things I want to talk about is
you know can you use it on you know
longer term charts you know I I like to
use range based charts and range based
charts aren't based on time right it's
based on price movement but you know
there's a lot of Traders out there that
like to use minute based charts like 1
minute 5 minute 15 minute and so on and
you know they're asking you know how
does it look on on a 5-minute chart cuz
you know most of my presentations I I
use range base charts so this is this is
a f minute
chart and you can see is giving you some
decent signals but again you know I I I
don't trade on 5 minute charts anymore
and again it's up to you if if you think
this is something that can suit you on a
5 minute
chart now you
know I say one of the the things to keep
in mind you know with with when you're
using you know minipage charts is
um you know people don't start trading
because hey it's 908 I I you know
training a minip page chart and it's
going to form a new bar so you know H go
don't don't necessarily think in that
term I mean the only way alos really um
think is you know when when a Trader's
got to enter an order okay into a market
the depending on the type of order right
if it's a vwap to put a time limit on it
if it's um you know percentage of volume
won't have a time limit on it's only
certain types of orders have time limits
on so you know if you're trading with
the minute based chart again you know
people don't sit around and say oh my
gosh it's 1:00 let's start buying um you
know unless they they've got some big
massive Market on close order to buy
50,000 e Minis maybe they'll start it a
little bit early but you know markets
don't base move based on on the clock
you know they move based on the buying
or selling that's why I prefer um
range-based charts where you know
markets you know a new bar is formed as
the Market's moving not as um you know
the clock ticks okay now here's
a euro currency the 6E the 5-minute
chart now you know is it getting some
nice moves yeah of course it's getting
some nice moves I mean look at this
11705 all the way down to
11675 another sell here um you know
another little sell here you know and a
buy going right into the close this is
where we are right now in the evening
session but again you
know can you use it on time based charts
yes of of course you can you know the
the Delta scalper works fine on um you
know range based charts minute based
charts ranco charts um you just the I
mean I wouldn't go out into something
like you know a 30 minute chart or an
hourly chart but you know it it's
designed more for short-term price
movement rather than you know something
you're going to buy and hold for 3 days
so that's why you know I you know I I
prefer to use range charts intraday cuz
I'm an intraday Trader and you know
minias charts on on more of uh you know
for short-term moves okay now if you're
really a uh cardiac kid you a Trader
that that really loves the action you
know look at the Dex this is a DEX this
is a one minute chart I'm showing you
right here and you know you get a sell
signal up here around the one uh the 12
215 area and boom it makes this nice
monster move down to um you know below
12150 you know starts covering back
covering back no signals yet this buy
that fail then you get a buy here it's a
nice little buy here it rallies up from
the 175 area up to the 195 you get get a
sell starts to work then it comes and
and comes right back on you just soon as
the you know once the cash session in
the US opens you get a big jump up there
this buy failed here later in the day
10:30 you get a nice Buy Signal here big
up bar then you know you're buying at
12200 and you know a rally up to
12 you know what is that 12 220 um you
and then we just sort of go into the
close here and just this slight dribble
get a little buy here that works out
this sell doesn't work out
and that's that's it it closes for the
day so you know I mean you people always
talk about oh you got to have good risk
reward ratio okay
well so you got one loser here one
winner here one we'll call this a loser
here so now you you got two losers One
winner three losers One winner and then
four winnner uh two winners four losers
okay so but but look at what you're
getting you're risk in this little tiny
bit here to catch a move like this here
of of 20 ticks so basically you're
risking you know three or four
ticks but you're getting back you know
20 ticks here
now again you got another winner here
and a small loser there so that's what
that's three winners five losers again
I'm not even counting this this move
here from 2 2115 all the way down to 150
which is you know 65 ticks I didn't even
count that okay but you know if if you
did it just blows out everything because
you know yeah you care less about this
little loss here when you're taking a
big winner like that you know again you
know so people you know always say oh
you know what's what's your risk reward
you know honestly I mean people don't
you know trade you at institutional
level they say what's your risk reward
you know for each trade they just say
you show me your p&l are you a winner
are you a loser
and you know again you got to you got
Define you know are you willing to take
this loss right here take one for the
team to catch this move here take this
loss here to catch you know and this
loss here to cat you know one loser in a
row two losers to catch this this winner
here you know can you do that can you
you know are you willing to do that um
you know can your mental state survive
it you know taking you know a loser here
a winner here a loser here a loser here
and then you know again catching the
nice winner here to get it all
back again I'm not a person that's going
to say you know look for the trades to
get it all back on um but again you know
even if I don't count this this trade in
here this you know 65 you know 70 tick
winner and you just looking at at these
little trades here you say oh I got a
loser here you got a loser here you got
you got this batch of um three trades
two of which were losers one of which
was a winner you know some people might
say they got stopped out on this you
know um depending on where they Place
their stop so you know even if you count
this as a loser um you're still in here
with this nice winner from 200 up to two
um
220 so you know even if you're losing
five ticks here five ticks here five
ticks here five ticks here you know you
got it back here in this trade and then
even this next trade you get back a
little bit more you have a small loser
here of of you know two or three
ticks so again it's about stay in the
course and you know survive
the the losing trades and and being
there to take advantage of of the
winning trades now you know there are
these quote trading gurus that will say
oh if you suffer three trades in a row
you know quit trading well you know stop
trading for the day well if you do that
then you know you're not going to be
around to catch this move now yeah I I
understand the whole concept of capital
preservation that's why you trade with
you know a small percentage you know you
put only a small percentage of risk in
each trade right you're not you don't
take take your trading account at the
start of the day and divide it by four
and that's your risk management no you
know you're trading at a much smaller
risk so that you know you could
withstand the loss the loss the loss the
loss to catch the winner right that
that's that's money management it's not
you know basically going all in on each
trade that after you have um one or two
losers you got to stop and put more
money into your account so and you know
hopefully this video resonates with some
of you guys U subscribe to my YouTube
channel to learn more about uh orderflow
trading visit orderflows outcom or visit
my other website Delta scalper on the
Delta scalper you know we've we've um
been doing a little bit of work uh we're
releasing a newer version of the Delta
scalper and you know it takes into price
action a little bit more so you know
it's definitely worth a look go to Delta
scalper there's a short video on on it
there as well so thank you and hope to
see you on the inside
bye-bye